Друзі, всім привіт! Уже листопад - час вмикати опалення.
Наприклад, цю квартиру опалює тепла підлога.
У кожній кімнаті - регулятор
для індивідуального налаштування температури.
Ось тут розташований лічильник і система
розведення під підлогою кімнат труб із водою,
яку в підвалі цього будинку підігріває газовий котел.
Пропоную розібратися, які ще типи опалення
існують у Німеччині і скільки тут платять за тепло.
86% будівель у Німеччині мають автономні системи опалення.
Природним газом обігрівається половина
всіх помешкань країни.
Газове опалення німцям обходиться найдешевше.
Опалення газовим котлом у квартирі
площею 70 кв. м. у 2018 році в середньому коштує
64 євро на місцяць, а, наприклад, котлом на мазуті -
67,5 євро на місяць.
Зимових та літніх тарифів на газ у Німеччині не існує.
Оплату рівномірно розподіляють на 12 місяців.
Завітаємо до приватних будинків.
Друзі, я приїхав у селище Свісталь-Одендорф,
щоб показати вам два класичних приклади
опалення в Німеччині.
Котел опалення в цьому будинку працює на газі, а в цьому – на мазуті.
З Єгором, який мешкає в Німеччині вже майже 20 років,
ідемо до підвалу будинку з газовим котлом,
щоб подивитися на серце системи опалення будинку.
Газовий котел "Вісман" встановили три роки тому.
Опалення коштує приблизно 2 тисячі євро на рік, залежно від зими.
Ним можна керувати через смартфон.
Якщо я сиджу де-небудь на Пальма-де-Майорка,
то я можу керувати своїм котлом, звісно,
і налаштувати його, щоб він нагрів мені будинок,
коли я буду повертатися додому.
Вартість котла і системи разом з оплатою робіт сягнула 8 тисяч євро.
Будинку вже понад 60 років, тож він потребував
модернізації системи опалення.
Будинок має три поверхи.
Житлова площа - 200 квадратних метрів.
Тепер зазирнемо у підвал сусіднього будинку
з котлом на мазуті.
Це система опалення від "Вісман" виробництва 2008 року.
Вона потребує близько двох тисяч літрів мазуту
на рік для опалення.
А ось тут розташований бак для мазуту.
Його встановили ще у 60-х роках.
Він вміщує до 4 з половиною тонн.
Ось така вантажівка розвозить паливо для мазутних котлів.
У Німеччині ціни на мазут  для опалення
услід за світовими цінами на нафту
підскочили за останній рік аж на чверть.
Нині сто літрів коштують 88 євро.
Мазут - друге паливо за популярністю у Німеччині після газу.
Ним обігрівають чверть усіх помешкань.
Їду до району Бонна Лессеніх, щоб побачити,
як працює котел на дерев’яних пелетах. І знову - у підвал.
Тут пахне свіжою сосною. Пелети мають чарівний аромат.
Власник будинку Фолькер Людвіґ розкручує систему,
щоб продемонструвати,
як шнек штовхає пелети в камеру спалювання.
Вони падають із приємним звуком.
Ну що ж, а тепер відкриємо цей котел на пелетах
і подивимося, що там усередині.
Для цього старого будинку на рік
треба приблизно 14 тонн пелетів.
Їхня вартість - три тисячі євро.
Експерт з енергоощадності Штефан Герпертц підкреслює,
що будинок кінця 60-х років площею 400 кв. м
не є енергоефективним і витрати на опалення після модернізації
і утеплення могли би бути меншими аж на 30-40%
Якщо б власник цього помешкання надумав, наприклад,
його здавати, йому було б це практично неможливо зробити.
За законом, кожна будівля повинна мати енергопаспорт,
щоб жильці могли приблизно оцінити
свої майбутні витрати на опалення.
Клас енергоспоживання цього будинку  - у графі літери Еф.
дуже низький показник. Відповідно, літера А
означає "найвища енергоефективність".
Цікаво, що навіть попіл від пелетів іде у справу.
Ми компостуємо наше органічне сміття з будинку
на компостній купі і пересипаємо його попелом
від згорілих дерев'яних пелетів.
Згодом виходить, як видно тут унизу,
ось така особливо родюча земля,
на якій дуже добре ростуть рослини.
Ось ці квіти в саду пана Людвіґа виросли
на компостному добриві з додаванням попелу пелетів.
Раз на рік проводиться контрольна перевірка
лічильників помешкання і корегується місячна оплата
на наступний рік. Якщо користувач був ощадливим,
переплату за опалення повернуть на його банківський рахунок.
Якщо "палив на повну", то отримає повідомлення про доплату.
Ну що ж, я прийшов до "Фербраухерцентралє" -
центр порад для споживачів.
Тут можна отримати консультацію з будь-якого питання.
Консультанти озброюють споживачів
найсвіжішими статистичними даними щодо витрат
на опалення в Бонні, щоб вони могли порівняти,
чи не переплачують за обігрів.
На макетах пояснюють принцип дії найостанніших
екологічних котлів для опалення
і роз'яснюють права споживачів.
Уже майже 10 років, як споживачі можуть змінювати
свого постачальника енергії. Раніше такого не було
і люди мусили обирали того, хто був у регіоні.
Можливість змінити постачальника енергії -
добре для споживача, бо є рух на ринку енергетичних послуг
і компанії намагаються знизити свої ціни.
Далі їду до боннської електростанції компанії SWB.
На ній, окрім електрики, виробляють ще й
тепло для системи центрального опалення.
Німецькою - "фернверме",
дослівно - "тепло на віддалі".
На вході - білборд із веселим інженером Рольфом Дріллером.
А ось і він сам запрошує мене всередину.
Це - бонський сміттєспалювальний завод.
Під час спалювання сміття виробляється гаряча пара,
яка ось цим трубопроводом подається на електростанцію.
На цю турбіну надходить пара зі сміттєспалювального заводу.
Її температура - 440 градусів.
Ця пара крутить турбіну,
яка виробляє електрику, а також нагріває воду
для центрального опалення.
Електростанцію будували три роки.
Здали в експлуатацію влітку 2013 року.
Вона коштувала 80 мільйонів євро.
У цьому синьому генераторі
виробляється струм потужністю 70 мегаватт.
Пара з турбіни надходить
до конденсатора, де на двох установках
потужністю по 60 мегаватт
виробляється гаряча вода
для центрального опалення Бонна.
По термоізольованому трубопроводу до споживача
вода під тиском подається з температурою
максимум 135 градусів за Цельсієм.
На електростанції очищують воду
перед потраплянням її до системи опалення,
щоб уникнути забруднення і забивання трубопроводу.
Ґрунтову воду ми тут декарбонізуємо,
знижуємо вміст вуглецю в ній
і за допомогою паленого вапна
робимо "тверду" ґрунтову воду м'якою.
Потім частину води також використовують
для охолоджувальної системи електростанції.
А працівники електростанції - ще й жартівники.
Ось там посадили рожевого фламінго,
щоб він контролював якість води.
У Німеччині 14% опалення - центральне.
Це нині найдорожчий тип опалення у ФРН.
Тепло з центрального опалення у квартирі площею 70 кв. м. у 2018 році
в середньому коштує 72,5 євро на місяць.
Переважно його використовують адміністративні будівлі й офіси.
Наприклад, у Бонні це будівля компанії Дойче Веллє
або центральний офіс німецької пошти Дойче Пост -
хмарочос Пост Тауер.
Давайте спустимося у підвал найвищої будівлі Бонна,
щоб подивитися на систему опалення.
Ось це теплообмінники для води,
яка надходить до нас взимку з температурою у 135 градусів
і під великим тиском. Теплообмінник передає тепло
до іншої, внутрішньої системи трубопроводів опалення будинку,
яка розходиться по всіх офісах.
Далі гаряча долає 163 метри вгору,
щоб обігріти всі 46 поверхів хмарочоса.
Останніми роками до центрального опалення
дедалі частіше підключають новозбудовані
сучасні будинки, зокрема цілі житлові комплекси.
У цій серії я розповів
про найрозповсюдженіші види опалення в Німеччині.
Якщо вам цікаво дізнатися про новітні високотехнологічні
та екологічні типи опалення,
які стають дедалі популярнішими в німців,
пишіть у коментарях, і я обов'язково
про це розповім у наступних серіях. До зустрічі!